j'allais les voir il hier au stade donc
à bailleul et donc la chaîne j'allais
voir revenir la fst pour pour revoir
cette ambiance qu'on a eu on a eu hier
c'est super sympa c'est super sympa de
voir qu'on est soutenue suivie et
appréciée par par notre ville et de
rentrer comme ça en vainqueur c'est
agréable montrer le soutien dans le
final c'est qu'on veut faire et puis
leur dire que la demi-finale bas il ay
combat si elle a gagné quoi même les
finales ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir
donc on voit qu'on a fait plaisir aux
gens voilà que qu'on ait soutenu voilà
donc il y avait trois quatre personnes
dernier tour là il y en a un peu plus
pourquoi bon on va pas en avoir plus
pour aller décrocher finalement si
jamais tu es t elle l a fait en même
temps je pense qu'on a tous un peu sur
un nuage depuis en maraude 200
tranquillement
[Applaudissements]